hookups Swanson it's like you said death
is natural and Sal lived a good long
life but so much is changing and I've
never been a fan of change Salvatore was
a constant in my life in my experience
the only constant is change now
nice to see you Ron I couldn't help but
overhear
Cherie I'm sorry about your loss and
every time we lose a compadre our
collective Lantern gets a little bit
dimmer hey you look awful familiar have
we met before I'm sure our souls have
collided in one lifetime or another no
that's not it
are you into my frisbee golf league oh
yeah I play for the super spinners huh
I'm on the frisbee champs oh cool I
named us Andrew stop speaking to this
man he is the worst human being on earth
come on death makes brother's of us all
I always found it when my soul aches
with loss it's best to turn to Eastern
wisdom this is from the Isle of ila and
Scotland misses his Eastern as my wisdom
gets Swanson this handsome spiritual
cowboy may actually be right about
turning to the east I have an idea
trust me who cuts your hair nobody I
never wear my hair feels it has
completed its journey it simply sheds
itself off I hate you so much and I love
you my brother Donna this is crazy
typhoon is an artist and the human head
is canvas just listen you're gonna cut
the man's hair you're gonna charge him
eight dollars it'll take you four
minutes so just shut up and make the man
look like this fine so typhoon what do
you like to do for fun
I'm writing an electronic opera about
Brittany Murphy and I do the chandelier
design for my friends drag puppet show
no further questions
all I really want to do is dance except
lately all the good warehouse waves are
filled with the Eurotrash Eurotrash I
don't like that it is indeed a garbage
come on yes oh my god I had the worst
time in Berlin last May everyone was on
their stupid bikes I was like ill please
talk more about how you hate Europe and
bicycles hello miss Knope hello former
strange person I used to friend
you're looking very Ron like you have
your same hair no I don't I have bangs
now I've never known what bangs are and
I don't intend to learn
maybe you should yeah you're not gonna
win 50 million dollars you freak maybe
not but I'm not not going to win nothing
Paul that guy is a joke this lawsuit is
definitely getting thrown out I don't
know those are John Ralphie has lawyers
he once got him sixty thousand dollars
cuz he got too scared of the haunted
house and what exactly did you witness
defendant alias Ron Swanson alias my
boss used appropriate force to prevent
further damage to the wedding of Leslie
Knope alias my other boss you sound as
if you have a special interest in law
enforcement yes sir
in fact at the time I was trying to
become a police officer but was deemed
unfit to the force and what happened
don't know well I poached the brain exam
just to be safe I wouldn't take anything
I say too seriously next witness your
honor
MS Ludgate have you ever heard mr.
Swanson threatened to hurt councilman
Jamm Ronnie are you kidding me I've
never heard him threat never at anyone
or anything the guy's like a vegetarian
look at him he's like a big old soft
teddy bear
his nickname around the office is softie
pants make huggable did you ever hear
mr. Swanson say he intended to injure
councilman Jamm before the day of the
wedding the answer is a flat no mom
doesn't really pay much attention to
other people I doubt he even knew you
existed also may I say for the record
that is a dope pocket square can I see
that bad boy Tom and April were
excellent witnesses in my defense
unfortunately every single word out of
their mouths was a lie there's only one
thing I hate more than lying skim milk
which is water that's lying about being
milk is that a travel pillow around your
neck run I don't know how to explain
this to you when you've been down in the
pit have you been in the pit no I
haven't gotten down there yet well I
have when you fill in when I visited the
bottom of the pit on a fact-finding
mission and when you're down there you
get some perspective about what it all
means let me tell you something wrong
what it means is I want this
subcommittee I've been quite open about
this around the office I don't want this
parks department to build any parks
because I don't believe in government I
think that all government is a waste of
taxpayer money my dream is to have the
park system privatized and run entirely
for profit by corporations like
chuck-e-cheese they have an impeccable
business model I would rather work for
chuck-e-cheese Ron Swanson it is my
pleasure to inform you that you are a
finalist for the job of assistant city
manager Chris I feel I should remind you
that I do not believe that the position
or the entire government should exist
that said you'd be a fool not to pick me
I will walk deeper into the belly of the
beast if it means I'm able to further
limit reckless government spending I
mean I have so many ideas some are
simple like take down traffic lights and
eliminate the post office the bigger
ones will be tougher like bring all of
this crumbling to the ground so after
all that it's really not that bad you're
gonna get a letter in your file Ron I
just wanted to say thanks to worry about
it
no I didn't I didn't do it for Leslie I
did it because I hate bureaucracy my
idea of a perfect government is one guy
who sits in a small room at a desk and
the only thing he's allowed to decide is
who to nuke the man has chosen based on
some kind of IQ test and maybe also a
physical tournament like a decathlon and
women are brought to him maybe when he
desires that hey bro
listen I was trying to buy this
handcrafted mahogany wood model of b-25
mitchell Panchito aircraft for me don't
sass me and I went to this website and
this ad popped up that said hey Ron
Swanson check out this great offer
what's your question my question is what
the hell like how did they know who you
are
yeah okay um there are these things
called cookies where like if you go to a
site and buy something it'll remember
you and then create ads for other stuff
you might want to buy so it learns
information about me seems like an
invasion of privacy dude if you think
that's bad go to Google Earth and type
in your address
well Diane for potholes you want to
speak with Public Works
I understand you've tried them four
times government is inefficient and
should be dissolved please hold while I
transfer you would you like to sample
our vegan bacon 100% meatless yes please
another please
sir is there a problem I'm just making
sure no one ever has to eat this I I
don't think I can give you any more I
want one what a gorgeous herbaceous
mentally there's been a mistake
you've accidentally given me the food
that my food eats salad is traditionally
the first course at a wedding is a
gerbil marrying a rabbit I couldn't care
less about the commendation
but Indianapolis is home to Charles
Mulligan's Steakhouse the best damn
Steakhouse in the damn State
I have taken a picture of every steak
I've ever eaten there June 2004
porterhouse medium-rare Bearnaise sauce
January 2000 they call this one the
enforcer February 96 a steak ribeye the
whiskey Lagavulin 16 the lady next to me
a [ __ ] specifically my ex-wife Tammy
okay this is this is the first time I
ever went there oh just a kid Ron would
you like some salad since I am NOT a
rabbit no I do not try it sounds good
for you you got it mmm delicious
from what in the devil's name is this
portobello mushrooms where's the steak
well there's no steak
that's a healthier option it's
organically grown okay okay can you get
us a cold conference or something
you